[Musique]
les micmacs l'appelle le bout du moule
gaspé 15000 habitants la plus grande
ville de la gaspésie elle attire de plus
en plus de touristes et son économie est
en pleine expansion avec notamment
l'agrandissement de l'usiné de pales
d'éoliennes lm wind power
c'est le plus beau que chez soleil que
ce que j'ai vu au québec ça c'est sûr
elise bernier et photographes et globe
trotter elle a parcouru le monde pendant
une dizaine d'années avant de déposer
ses valises à gaspé
la pandémie a vraiment aidé pour ça
c'est ce que pousser sûrement fait parce
que bon d'une part les voyages est en
arrêt mais d'une autre ou six mois je
travaillais pour une boîte à montréal
que qui a dû fermer ses portes pendant
la pandémie et j'ai eu 9 de venir passer
l'été en gaspésie je tombe en amour j'ai
acheté un terrain
à
coups de coeur moi je trouve que c'était
vraiment un milieu qui me représentais
du coup avec la mâture
dans le centre ville plusieurs nouveaux
commerces se sont installés évidemment
un côté plus urbain
elsa ould est une ancienne menteuse
vidéo elle a ouvert sa boulangerie au
début de la deuxième vague il y a un an
et demi un changement de vie complet car
elle a dû tout apprendre
au chaud native dagas riz
puis je suis parti pour les études j'ai
travaillé télévision j'ai rester comme
25 ans à montréal mais j'étais toujours
un peu stand by j'avais vraiment envie
de m'impliquer les étoiles se sont
alignées il y avait pas de boulangerie à
gaspé je connaissais bien le milieu je
pense que l'expérience de la vie que
jamais
me donner confiance pour bâtir une
entreprise qui allait plaire
j'avais lu ar est aussi d'origine
gaspésienne
elle travaillait à montréal dans un café
et vivait dans un quartier branché mais
elle songeait depuis quelques temps à se
lancer en affaires et ouvrir son propre
café à gaspé
[Musique]
ans à venir s'établir à moyen long terme
avec les enfants on pensait pas le faire
aussi tôt mais c'était dans les plantes
on s'ennuyait de la famille on
s'ennuyait de la main aussi qu'ils ont
été un peu tanné de chaos un peu du
chaos d'aviles l'aco vide a été
certainement un accélérateur
[Musique]
à part des miens orio certaines des
faits également parce que les gens
voulaient découvrir ou retrouver de plus
grands espaces et la gaspésie est sorti
du lot faire que vos régions excentrées
que connut bravo une croissance marquée
[Musique]
90 kilomètres de là nous sommes amers
dogville trois montagnes de la belle
poudreuse des paysages à couper le
souffle deux mille skieurs viennent
maintenant chaque année d'un peu partout
au québec en plus des gens de la région
[Musique]
élise fait le trajet régulièrement de
gaspé pour profiter de ce haut lieu de
la randonnée alpine
et du ski hors piste
[Musique]
le tout la sauce à spaghetti félix rioux
et un photographe de ski il ya beaucoup
voyagé lui aussi mais il rêvait de vivre
un jour à la montagne avec sa conjointe
roxane et leurs trois enfants
on s'attendait pas à ça on était en
pleine pandémie à montréal un gros
confinement et puis au mois de mai
guillaume moléson
cofondateur du chic chocs qui il
m'appelle dans tout déménagé en gaspésie
pourquoi pas si ça va pas bien en ce
moment on est confiné chez nous pourquoi
pas essayer quelque chose d'autre
c'était quand même un saut dans
l'inconnu murdoch ville est une ancienne
ville minière qui a bien failli fermer
il ya 20 ans lorsque la mine de cuivre a
cessé ses opérations
bien des gens sont partis les maisons ne
valait plus rien
vous allez pouvoir percevoir toute la
chaîne des succès qu'au fond la gauche
c'est guillaume raisons qui lui a donné
un second souffle en misant sur le ski
et le tourisme d'aventuré
son entreprise le chic chaque vient
d'ailleurs de s'installer dans
l'ancienne église transformée en
quartier général avec un bar une salle
de spectacle
[Musique]
on sent vraiment que la pandémie a
exacerbé le phénomène de retour en
région terminent nouveaux arrivants
belle dynamique
ils les phénomènes aussi la tendance du
ski hors piste tout ça mis ensemble avec
la manche de projets de l'église avait
fait un beau me bob immobilier quand on
est à vue est une des premières maisons
qui faisait des rénovations majeures les
gens à se promener sa rue peel était
content de voir ça médias et investissez
pas trop le thé faites attention parce
que sa patte ça vaut rien les maisons
murdoch puis un ami de tarlé toutes les
maisons de litres puis cette maison leur
a coûté seulement dix-huit mille dollars
elle en vaut presque dix fois plus
aujourd'hui peu après ils ont convaincu
leurs voisins de montréal de déménager
aussi les enfants sont ravis tout est
plus facile ils peuvent aller à l'école
à pied
mais ici cette nouvelle vitalité à
servair il n'y a pas assez de logements
pour accueillir les nouveaux arrivants
et c'est encore plus vrai à gaspé où ils
manquent de garderie et de services en
fait le plus gros défi cros connaît
présentement c'est le logement en fait
on m'a même sur 2 soutenu la
construction de logements il ya d'abord
pour moi qu'on ne connaît pas capable de
rattraper cette croissance démographique
ne manquerait combien le logement vous
diriez pour une ville comme gaspé ont
parlé de 300 à 400 nouvelles unités qui
serait nécessaire pour soutenir les
besoins qu'ils souhaitent et les besoins
de croissance qui sont anticipés
et si on est une terre entre montagne et
mer puis pour moi c'est le meilleur des
deux mondes mais autant j'adore être
dans l'eau donc faire la plonge et du
sort aujourd'hui un peu dingue mais
enfin qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est
compliqué pour eux pour se garder en
forme du monde le dit si vous aller bon
train quand l'hiver arrive le fait c'est
la meilleure saison alors que tout le
monde vient ici on était là j'ai
vraiment vécu l'hiver
c'est vrai que c'est un jeu qui est
exceptionnel
ils ont le champ libre en fête pour
innover réaliser leurs aspirations
il donne un nouveau dynamisme à cette
terre d'accueil
j'étais à moitié installés à gaspé quand
j'ai commencé à parler j'avais envie de
faire ce projet le fou fou fou comment
les gens ils m'ont mon post soutenu ils
m'ont enlevé
elsa oui il nous faut ça
on va encourager vos voir un tel les
subventions telles place j'ai eu le
tellement de feedback je pense que les
gens ici ont faim consciemment choisi
l'entraînent plutôt que la compétition
en état j'ai pas sept minutes la
montagne pour aller faire du sns qui
fait pour saab ainsi des plus plus et
qu'on profite de l'extérieur de jeu s'en
sortant de la maison on est proche car
ferions les proches de la plage je viens
de porto rico donc c'est un gros
changement ce jeu mannheim un peu plus
mais je suis ainsi à côté de la mer
aussi donc c'est ça que j'aime le plus
c'est plus juste vive la vie comme ça tu
n'as pas de stress ce str inquiet
les jeunes qui reviennent ici c'est
paris en eau déchets qui sont à
l'extérieur mais il revient dans leur
coin de pays tu encore jean fauque a eu
des années cabeza beaucoup que le
manceau n'a là mais servier ça veut dire
que on est petit accueillant jamais je
n'oublierai de la gaspésie sur les
résidents murdoch les anciens de la
ville ils sont très très content de voir
des jeunes familles s'installent et
parce que ça ramène de l'énergie pour
rien vendre notre vie on fait quelque
chose d'autre on prend cette opportunité
le pot mathieu 0 puis voir qu'est-ce
qu'on peut martyre d'un nouveau royaume
l'esquissé ce qui a apporté un menu
ville c'est une raison à des jeunes
venus s'établir
2 dès qu'on a plus de front deux
carrières puis qu'on est fier d'être ici
on voit qu'il est un bel engouement que
les gens sont présents je pense que on
écrit un lieu que les gens aient un
tiercé en blanc est un milieu de vie que
j'adore donc je me vois vraiment pas
partir pour l'instant j'ai envie de
m'investir aussi dans dans mon milieu
l'adage africain qui dit que ça prend un
village pour élever un enfant mais ici
j'ai trouvé beaucoup plus que sur la
rive sud
un enfant cécile c'est magique
[Musique]